y la muerte hace una semana de un agente
de policía en bogotá en luto a esta
entidad este oficial murió por arma de
fuego mientras realizaba sus labores de
patrullaje el capturado por su crimen es
un extranjero ataques como éste se
refirió la alcaldesa de bogotá claudia
lópez en la presentación de su nueva
estrategia para combatir la criminalidad
en la capital tener un comando de
policía inmigración que nos ayude a
combatir las estructuras criminales
de población migrante que
desafortunadamente está haciendo un
factor de inseguridad en nuestra ciudad
el anuncio de la alcaldesa generó una
reacción de la comisión interamericana
de derechos humanos quien expresó su
preocupación y es que esta no es la
primera vez que la alcaldesa habla de
una relación entre los crímenes y la
población migrante tenemos actos muy
violentos de inmigrantes venezolanos
este no es un tema de hurto
primero
asesinan y luego roban frente al nuevo
comando anunciado por la alcaldesa la
autoridad migratoria del país quiso
desmarcarse los migrantes venezolanos en
colombia son gente buena que está
saliendo adelante y estamos llenos de
múltiples ejemplos de personas que nos
han enseñado con su ejemplo a avanzar
como sociedad colombia alberga 1,7
millones de emigrantes venezolanos 340
mil de ellos viven en bogotá del total
700 59 mil están en situación regular y
983.000 en situación irregular
representan menos del 1 8% de los 97 mil
detenidos que hay en toda colombia por
actos delictivos los mil 645 de los 82
mil hurtos que se cometen son cometidos
por migrantes entonces vemos realmente
que así que una cacería de brujas contra
la población migrante lo que resulta que
no corresponde con la realidad y es que
la mayoría de los hechos delictivos se
cometen por parte de colombianos desde
comienzos de año colombia avanza en la
aplicación de un estatus temporal de
protección para migrantes venezolanos
una medida con la que el gobierno aspira
a acelerar su regularización